like I I'd heard things like oh you know
they won't let you show this to the
Disney show and I'm like okay so I was a
little like susque when I started our
leadership over there has been so
welcoming to like my like not at all
secret gay agenda and so like I I feel
like
I don't have
[Music]
it
this doesn't look too good Patrick we
were doomed from the start the proud
family was originally a kid show on the
Disney Channel back in the early 2000s
it was canceled in 2005 and then in 2022
it became uh just the latest reboot that
nobody needed nobody asked for nobody
wanted I don't wanna I don't want to do
this anymore the rebooted proud family
which can be found now on Disney plus
promises to be louder and prouder and it
certainly fulfills at least half of that
promise and here it is built this
country and we the descendants of slaves
in America have earned reparations for
their suffering and continue to earn
reparations every moment we spend
submerged in the systemic Prejudice
racism and white supremacy that America
was founded with and still has not a
town for slaves built this country not
only field hands but Carpenters Masons
blacksmiths
tricks and techniques that I've learned
over eight or more years now of having
you growing a beard beards are very
different our account is still
outstanding because this country was
built on slavery with me slaves built
this country and we demand our 40 acres
and a mule you can keep the mule keep
the 40.
just some nice wholesome children's
content and most importantly and it is
really necessary that we emphasize that
slaves did not build this country how
dare you the building started in the
1400s when the first European explorers
sailed across treacherous and Uncharted
Seas to discover these lands it
continued with the European settlers in
the 1500s and 1600s who built a life for
themselves in this unknown Wilderness
facing Untold threats and for many of
them certain death this country was
built by the colonists and the American
revolutionaries it was built by War and
conquest by Discovery by diplomacy by
industry the country was built by the
people who made it into the world's
great power in the 20th century who won
World Wars and brought about peace and
economic Prosperity it was built by many
people over many centuries and for a
portion of that history some people in
some parts of the country own slaves
that certainly is not enough to justify
the claim that the slaves built the
country it never happened it's fiction
to make that claim is to erase nearly
everyone who really did build the
country it's to paper over America's
actual history with your
grievance-mongering nonsense as many of
you know I'm a true Grill Master I love
growing up just about anything thanks to
my friends at cinch my grill is never
empty with propane since it's a propane
grill tank Home Delivery Service they
deliver propane tanks right to your door
since delivers on your schedule does not
require any long-term commitment or
subscription plus delivery is completely
contactless you don't have to wait
around at home track the order on the
Cinch app from anywhere whether you're
grilling for your friends camping with
your family or lighting up your fire pit
on a cold summer night since just
propane delivery service ensures that
you have the fuel you need to make the
most of every moment go online to
cinch.com or download their app to order
new customers can get their first tank
exchange for just ten dollars of promo
code Walsh that's Cyn ch.com promo code
Walsh is a limited time offer and you
must live within a cinch service area to
redeem it visit cinch.com offer for
details now if the mere historical fact
of slavery automatically means that the
country was built by slavery every and
forever is indebted to slaves and their
descendants then of course the same must
be said about every nation on the planet
there is no race no people uh no Nation
anywhere in the world who does not
inherit the guilt of of slavery we all
did it as I will never Tire of pointing
out the only thing that makes America's
relationship to slavery unique is how
comparatively quickly we abolished it
and the lengths we went to abolish it
God bless America you notice something
you notice how I didn't use the word we
when talking about the people who did
build the country I didn't come here on
the Mayflower I wasn't on the Lewis and
Clark expedition I didn't fight in the
Civil War I didn't storm the beaches of
Normandy people who looked kind of like
me did but I didn't so I don't take
credit for their achievements or claim
their accolades just as I don't pretend
to have experienced their suffering or
felt their pain I stand at the end of
this long line of Triumph and sacrifice
I am its beneficiary and so are you what
whatever your race yet in that Disney
song that's not really a song we hear
the word we being used
and this is always the case with the
race Hustlers they talk about the long
ago sufferings of people they never met
and who they missed meeting by a century
and a half and they say we and us but no
it's not a we are enough situation
because you were not enslaved it may
have happened to your ancestors but if
you go back a little further you may
just as well find that your ancestors
did it to others damn Hypocrites make me
sick this is this is the problem of
trying to claim your entire lineage as
if it all happened to you is that you
cannot isolate this one particular
moment in your ancestry and take direct
ownership of it speaking about it as if
you were there without owning all of the
rest of your ancestral history so
alternatively you can choose to stand in
the present
appropriating neither your ancestors
achievements nor their sufferings
nor their sins it's your choice really
you've got two paths and one gives you a
chance at Living a happy and successful
life the other keeps you wallowing
pathetically in self-pity obsessing over
resentments that don't belong to you
it's up to you all you have to decide
is what to do with the time that is
given to you